I'm going to knock you out Mama Said
Knock You
Out the mass singer season 4 has
returned and unfortunately the dragon
got
[Applause]
slain the one and only hip hop Legend oh
man buzz buzz buzz H goodbye bust to
rymes sadly his fire was not hot enough
to keep him in this competition oh I
just adore Buster rymes that signature
voice that I think we recognized as soon
as he stepped on stage I'm disappointed
that he went home first because I know
he would have brought a lot of energy to
Future performances I agree he would
have brought the heat but luckily there
are plenty of other new things this
season that are definitely upping the
competition I'm super excited about it
obviously uh in the world we are
currently living in Amid coid and the
pandemic there is not an audience there
but it does look like there is the EP
spoke about it actually in another
interview and said how it's kind of an
augmented reality audience it's making
us think they're sitting there they're
not it's all put in there in post-
production I think it's so awesome and
it was convincing to me I mean I
believed there were people there and on
top of that the clue packages another
huge thing we noticed right away is
they're all animated this year it was
really cool it felt like I was watching
a cartoon instead of us normally seeing
them filming them in different places
around Los Angeles and another big
change this season is the stage in years
past of course they were filming on a
sound stage and don't worry they still
are but with the benefit of all this
technology they've now integrated some
really cool like CGI looking shots um so
you might notice a couple like aerial
shots or or things from up above um the
thing that I'm most excited about though
this season is that not only are the
contestants competing the judges are
also now competing so Robin Jenny Ken
and Nicole are going to be weighing in
with a very important first impression
of each costume they have to submit it
and then when that character is revealed
they will get a point if they correctly
identified the per the star from the
get-go so they're going to be buying for
what they are calling the golden ear
mask the other thing Charlie I know that
you are very amped on this this is the
first time that we're going to see a
twers costume so of course we've got the
snow owls this season conjoined we saw
them perform tonight and uh we'll get
into that as we take it down through
what went down on the premiere of season
4 of the mass singer that's right there
are so many exciting things we're going
to jump right into it with our first
performer who certainly brightened up
the premiere take a look at the
[Applause]
[Music]
sun oh my gosh Blown Away by that
performance Charlie and I are going with
Leanne rymes one of the most iconic
vocalists who has so much talent and of
course only someone with that much
talent could cover lizzo's song cuz I
love you and uh guys Leanne has actually
performed well sang this song before
take a
listen
cryz I love
you I want a recording I always say this
for the best songs that people cover on
the show that was beautiful I loved it
and there was actually a clip that the
mass singer posted a head of tonight's
Premiere and I think the internet fully
agreed with us that it's just a
recognizable voice you know it and I
think we're pretty confident in saying
lean what else did you find so in the
clue package we saw Disney ears or like
a Mickey Mouse shape and if you've
studied Leanne's career if you're a fan
of hers you know that she has been with
the house of mouse practically
throughout her career there have been
several instances where she has either
performed a Disney song hung out at
Disneyland she actually had her own
Disney Channel original concert back in
the 90s on the Disney Channel so you
know that she's she's in thick with
Mickey Mouse I listen I support Disney
songs obviously I'm hoping we get her
singing one as well now and one more
thing from the clue package we often
talk about how the clue packages dive
into some things we may not know about
people's lives and we uh we got a brief
mention of depression that the son may
have gone through at some point in their
career life um and we actually do know
that Leanne has been very open about her
struggles with depression her childhood
stardom her parents' divorce and even
her own divorce uh she even mentioned
that she sought treatment in 2012 and
that is public knowledge so I think it's
interesting that it's kind of hidden in
the package there and it's something we
were able to find out as well much like
the giraffe's neck we are reaching to
figure out who this is take a listen
everybody everybody let get into it
let's get
stupid get it started get it started
listen I'm stumped and this is the
tallest costume in Mass singer history
they said it it's close to 8 ft which I
think is ironic cuz the costume is so
tall but our list of guesses is oh so
very short I have to say this one was
the biggest head scratcher for me all
night uh I I was trying to analyze the
voice I was trying to analyze the clues
I I I don't know I really don't know it
could be a comedian there were nods to
jokes and then you know throwing
Tomatoes um at the stage um I also feel
like it could be a former musician this
is someone who said that music is in
their blood so I don't know a few early
names that came out you know just that
jumped into my brain Vanilla Ice maybe
Chad Hanks Tom hanks's son I also feel
like the the raspy quality of the voice
it really reminds me of one of my
favorite actors Devin Sawa from Casper
and and so many other films that we know
and love in our hearts this could be him
trying to do something like totally out
of left field where did your brain go I
think I was focused on The Voice a lot
as well and what the singing kind of
sounded like did it sound like a singer
did it sound like someone who's trying
to sing for the first time and I don't
think it was bad but I think the song
was definitely more talkative so we
didn't necessarily hear them like try to
sing notes like the Sun so I can't
definitively say that like oh it is a
singer it's not a singer but it does
seem like someone who has at least
dabbled in music once before the other
thing that I was really paying attention
to was performance quality you know
we've seen people on the show in the
past like the Frog like the turtle who
can really kind of transcend to stage
and and just move so effortlessly I feel
like I was watching the giraffe and he
was kind of sedentary not really moving
a whole lot a little bit of grooving but
I don't know if this is someone who
maybe necessarily made their living off
of being a showman or being a huge
Dynamic performer on stage so I don't
know we're just going to keep racking
our brains and and picking apart these
Clues week after week because this
wasn't enough for me it wasn't enough I
agree take a look at the first Double
Trouble costume the snow out
[Music]
[Applause]
anywhere oh an emotional performance
that really tued at our heartstring
Charlie and I are going to go with Clint
Black and his wife Lisa we saw a clue
that was like a clamshell with a pearl
in the center while Clint and Lisa have
a daughter named Lily Pearl she has
actually even sang with them before so
she's part of the musical family also we
did see them kind of walking towards a
gingerbread house covered in snow well
Christmas is coming and Clint Black did
put out a Christmas album in 1995 and
another one in 2018 that Lisa also sang
on and I think their daughter did as
well so Christmas is definitely a part
of their family there and on top of that
we heard them say you haven't seen us in
a while during the clue package Clint
hasn't put out an album in over 5 years
so I think that's a big part and
actually ET just spoke with them when
they were presenting at the acms so
there's a lot of them coming back into
the public eye I think this show would
be the perfect thing for that I adore
them as a couple but I have one very
hard-hitting question are they gonna
hatch from that damn egg are we gonna
see them emerge out of the egg and like
actually explore the stage next week I
don't that egg had wheels on it so Dedra
I don't think they're getting out of it
I think they will be rolled on and off
that stage there will be no performing I
know you want that but they deserve to
be released from that egg maybe one day
well our next performer was certainly a
tough Colonel to pop take a
look about
[Music]
Allin that voice oh oh my goodness those
vocals now Charlie and I think that this
is a name we've thrown out in the past
we're going popcorn darling love we saw
jumbo sized heart and I built a career
around love so I think that's her doing
a little like a wink wink at her last
name the other clue that kind of tipped
me off was mirror mirror on the wall
what makes me the biggest Miracle of all
and if you're a Darlene fan of course
you know her album age of Miracles this
is definitely a legendary voice I think
this is very much in the same realm as
the glattus Knight Dion Warwick Patty L
bells and darling love is up to that
caliber so I think it makes perfect
sense for her to come on and sing on
this show and another legend that we
heard the judges throw of in their
guesses was Tina Turner and we saw kind
of a red hairing clue in the end of the
package it was a Mary go around that
said Proud Mary go around Proud Mary
obviously being Tina Turner's hit song
Darlene has covered it before so that
kind of makes sense there they're in the
same group of people and on top of that
there was a Broadway mention on a bus
that went by during the end of the clue
package Darlene has been in four
Broadway production most recently the
hairspray production I just think it
makes sense I don't know I'm kind of
stuck on darling love yeah and I I I
just I love the idea of people wanting
it to be Darlene Love in years past and
maybe that getting back to Darlene and
her maybe being convinced to do a show
like this well that is all we have for
group a we are off to an incredible
start for season 4 and we can show you
who is going to be performing next week
in group b and in a few weeks we will be
seeing Group C as well I am so excited
there are some legendary performers in
this competition and I can't wait to see
them get unmasked and of course keep it
locked here on ET for all things Mass
singer we will be taking you through the
entire season all the way through and
you know Charlie and I absolutely love
guessing along with you on Twitter and
on Instagram so DM us who you think is
behind the mask and with that said you
guys do the right
thing wear a mask and we'll see you next
[Music]
time